[Applaudissements]
il ya quelques jours
j'entre dans une boulangerie il ya une
dizaine de personnes qui font la queue
devant moi je m'attends à ce que les
personnes éventuellement voit qu'il ya
une deuxième caisse qui vient s'ouvrira
à côté parce que le vendeur vient de
nous y invite et en design et mesdames
et messieurs rejoignez moi ici je viens
d'où vient cette deuxième caisse et bien
croyez moi ou pas il n'y a pas une
personne qui bouge
les gens restent scotchés dans la
première fils et je suis le seul à faire
quelques pas et aller vers la deuxième
caisse alors je suis très surpris je
demande au vendeur gimmick comment vous
expliquez ça c'est quand même curieux
vous savez ce qui me répond ça c'est les
parisiens ils ont toujours peur de se
faire arnaquer toujours tort de faire
arnaquer est ce que votre pas que c'est
quand même grave vous un pays dans
lequel chacun a peur de son voisin dans
lequel on a atteint un tel niveau de
défiance de tous vis-à-vis de tous alors
ce sujet de la confiance et de la
défiance
en fait c'est un sujet qui me taraude
depuis une bonne dizaine d'années en
fait j'avais observé que dans des
entreprises ou dans des administrations
est bien plus il y avait de défiance qui
en général n'est 7 ou plus au niveau de
ses organisations que ce soit donc en
général au niveau des équipes de
direction des dirigeants eux-mêmes et
bien plus on pouvait observer du
désengagement de la démotivation des
arrêts de travail des conflits parfois
même grave ou violent et à l'époque
simplement le problème c'est que
j'observais ce phénomène mais j'étais
incapable de le l'analyse est
précisément de savoir quelles étaient
les composantes précises de cette
confiance ou de cette défiance dont
j'étais incapable de mesurer cette
confiance ou cette défiance et par là
même j'étais incapable
beaucoup de mal à agir concrètement
dessus ça c'est l'expérience
professionnelle ensuite sur un plan plus
personnel je puis dire comme vous sans
doute il ya eu cet événement qui a été
assez forte en dramatique en il ya
quelques années en 2011 vous souvenez la
révolution des printemps arabes
ça touche et la libye la tunisie et
l'egypte et qu'est ce qu'on a constaté
dans ces pays et bien que des pays dans
lesquels les peuples finissait par
développer un niveau de défiance
considérable dans leur élite qu'elle
soit politique économique ou même
médiatique
eh bien ces peuples finissait par
prendre les armes et résultats en
général
eh bien ça se transformait tout ça en un
véritable bain de sang est plus proche
de nous en europe en france ou aux états
unis par exemple eh bien cette défiance
croissante
elle se traduit comment par des la
montée des extrémismes par les
populismes et voire même par la
radicalisation
il suffit de voir en france les
élections
ces dernières années la montée de ces
extrémistes
elle est bien présente 1 vous constatez
comme moi et ça c'est vraiment très très
grave
alors ce que je vous dis là eh bien je
voulais partager
il ya 5 6 ans dans fin 2011 avec une
centaine de personnes de mon entourage
ou un peu éloigné de tous horizons et
ces gens m'ont dit ah mais oui puis à
bien sûr tu as raison c'est un vrai
sujet il faut qu'on agisse sur ce
domaine de la confiance et la défiance
on peut pas rester simplement spectateur
ce problème là donc on a créé ensemble
une infime tank c'est à dire un groupe
de réflexion la statue confiance qui a
engagé trois ans de recherche et
développement pour dans un premier temps
d'attenté de concrètement identifié deux
qu'on parle c'est quoi la confiance et
la défiance tant que ça reste un mot
valise
faites moi confiance je vous fais
confiance on sait pas de quoi on parle
comme je le disais est là donc on a
essayé de comprendre de quoi il
s'agissait pour qu'on puisse enfin peut
être mesuré cela est peu
réagir de suite et donc la bonne
nouvelle oui il ya une bonne nouvelle et
c'est cela que je veux partager avec
vous aujourd'hui c'est que oui la
confiance on sait aujourd'hui de quoi
elle a composé
oui la confiance on peut la mesurer et
oui la confiance on peut agir dessus
enfin alors ce travail devait rechercher
développement dont je vous ai parlé il a
donné naissance à un bel arbre qu'on a
appelé l'arbre de confiance alors comme
vous le voyez ce bel arbre
eh bien il est composé de sept pièces de
puzzle chacune d'entre elle correspond à
un type de comportement ou d'attitudes
qui contribuent à créer un climat de
confiance une culture de confiance à
tous les niveaux et si on a présenté
cela sous forme de pièces de puzzle
c'est pas par hasard c'est parce que
c'est différent comportement ou attitude
sont toutes un briquet intimement les
uns dans les autres
je vais en prendre un premier celui qui
est au milieu à droite
l'acceptation du droit à l'échec ou à
l'erreur aussi je prends celui là c'est
pas vraiment un hasard c'est parce que
vous faites pour vous pour vous faire un
petit aveux sur celui là deux facteurs
comportementale et ben à titre personnel
je suis pas vraiment de cette belle
couleur verte
je serais plutôt rouge vif c'est à dire
que je suis très éloigné de cette
culture-là de l'acceptation du droit à
l'échec à l'erreur est ce que vous
voulez un exemple récent le tedx là qui
nous amène à être ensemble aujourd'hui
ici est ce que vous savez combien de
versions de mon texte que je suis en
train de vous dire là j'ai préparé je
donne dans le mille
combien 5 ha ha les fêtes
c'est quoi il en faire déjà non 27-27
version et merci jusque là ça va tout va
bien à ces gentils en tous les cas ce
que je peux vous dire simplement c'est
que les coaches qui nous ont accompagnés
formidablement que je tiens à remercier
et ben je peux vous dire que les pauvres
ils se sont farcis les vingt-sept
version les unes après les autres
croient qu'ils n'en peuvent plus
d'ailleurs ils ont des cernes jusque là
voyez donc ça c'est vraiment alors ça
c'est un exemple personnel
maintenant je vais vous en donner un
deuxième qui est assez frappant aussi
est intéressant je crois c'est un
manager d'équipé dans une entreprise qui
lui aussi avait constaté qu'il était au
rouge vif comme moi sur ce droit à
l'échec à l'erreur et comment est-ce
qu'il a expliqué cela eh ben il a dit la
chose suivante qui est assez étonnante
il a dit à savez j'ai le syndrome du bon
élève
ah qu'est-ce que vous le dire par là ah
bah oui
comprenez quand j'étais enfant mes
parents et les profs me taper sur les
doigts d j'avais de mauvaises notes
ça vous parle résultat des courses ça se
ressent encore dans mon attitude
aujourd'hui
et quand je suis avec mes collaborateurs
et que je leur demande de s'engager de
prendre des risques de faire preuve
d'initiative de me dire lorsqu'ils ont
un problème avec qu'est ce qui se passe
il ya rien qu'elle monte parce que j'ai
beau leur dire ça ils ressentent que je
ne m'autorise pas moi-même au droit le
chèque ou de l'erreur dont des facto une
seule n'autorise pas non plus alors ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que quand un
de ces facteurs de conscience comme
celui là est tout rouge vif le problème
c'est que ça a des conséquences sur
d'autres pièces de puzzle est par
exemple si on reste sur l'exemple que je
viens de vous donner
eh ben ça va vouloir dire que ça va
entraîner le fait que ben ça va être du
chacun pour soi ça va être de l'hyper un
vie dure individualisme dans l'équipe de
ceux de ce gars dont je viens de parler
donc une coopération qui est très faible
et rouge
et puis même pire que ça les gens vont
se renvoyer la patate chaude ça va être
on va ce voyage c'est la faute de
l'autre je me renvoie la vraie celle du
chef qui est technique et responsable du
problème donc bienveillance 0 et puis
enfin troisième aspect troisième
conséquence
et bien comme je le disais tout à
l'heure la prise de risque la ligne les
prises la prise d'initiative et cetera
très faibles les gens n'osent pas non
plus donc l'acceptation de la certitude
du risque et de la complexité
elle est aussi rouge vif alors la
réalité elle est donc elle est donc
complexe
alors avant d'aller plus loin je
voudrais peut-être vous demander
d'ailleurs à propos
là on parle de moi des autres et vous là
dedans et vous là dedans alors vous avez
effectivement des cartons là certains
d'entre vous pas forcément tout le monde
mais vous en avez peut-être certains
avoir des petits cartons vert jaune
orange rouge
alors je vais vous poser la question à
vous dans le fond si vous vous plongez
dans votre propre vécu dans vos propres
votre histoire dans vos propres
comportements comment vous voyez en
attire d'acceptation du droit à l'échec
ou à l'erreur alors est ce que vous
pouvez me dire qu'ils se voient ouvert
c'est-à-dire plutôt à l'aise avec ça
alesi qui se voit à l'aise y en a mais
il n'y a pas foule
y a pas foule merci bravo qui se voit
jaune quand même pas mal bien merci qui
se voit orange c'est à dire commencer à
avoir un petit problème là vous êtes
assez nombreux et qui se voit au rouge
qui se voit rouge
ah oui vous êtes quand même assez
nombreux malgré tout bon donc notre lot
les rouges et leur range pour ce que
vous êtes un peu majoritaires quand un
ami 6 1
eh bien écoutez bienvenue au club en
fait mais rassurez vous on n'est pas les
seuls
on est dans un pays dans laquelle il ya
une culture du droit à l'échec ou en
europe n'est pas vraiment au vert c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire en france
enfin si ça peut vous rassurer il ya
quand même pas que la france non plus
alors avant d'aller plus loin
est ce que vous voulez que je vous dise
rapidement quels sont les trois autres
facteurs qui reste c'est sûr
lorsque j'aurai pas vous frustré que
vous rentriez mécontents chez vous ce
soir
bon alors je vais juste les décrire
rapidement un plus vite que ce que je
n'ai fait pour l'instant alors le
suivant c'est la cohérence entre paroles
et actes et l'authenticité alors ça se
traduit par la question comment partager
et jusqu'au mans et jusqu'au communiquer
sur mes intentions
c'est le rapport entre ce qu'on dit et
les intentions qui sont sous-jacents qui
ne sont pas toujours les mêmes et ça ça
peut poser un vrai problème de confiance
le suivant il un petit peu plus complexe
à comprendre c'est ce qu'on a appelé l'
indépendance de jugement face aux
conflits d'intérêts au conflit de
valeurs
ça renvoie à la question comment on
arrive à concilier des intérêts
divergents voire même contradictoires et
puis enfin le dernier
c'est la question du rapport au temps la
temporalité alors celui là il faut
l'entendre sous deux dimensions deux
angles le premier c'est le rapport entre
le présent et l'avenir
en fait c'est comment est ce que vous
arrivez à concilier ou pas un projet à
court terme avec une vision à long terme
et puis l'autre d'un autre dimension
c'est le rapport entre le présent et le
passé
quelqu'un qui vous a trahis tromper
faire sale coup voire même planté un
vrai couteau dans le dos et bien ce que
vous allez facilement réussir à oublier
voire main à pardonner cette personne là
fortiori si vous avez à vivre avec cette
personne au quotidien ou à travailler
avec elle au quotidien
on connaissait que c'est pas forcément
évident alors la question qui se pose au
final c'est comment on fait pour faire
revenir aux verts mais belles couleurs
de l'arbre vert un arbre individuel
d'une équipe une entreprise d'un
collectif plus large qui serait plutôt
jaune orange ou rouge vifs
voyez vous le rappeler automnale c'est
pas facile
et si vous voulez y parvenir il n'y a
pas cinquante solutions il faut oser
faire une chose qui est loin d'être
évidente
c'est d'arriver à creuser dans les
racines
de cet arbre et kidira sine die par
définition sous jacent invisible voire
même inconscient ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'on plonge là dans le champ
complexe des croyances des peurs de des
valeurs de l'héritage culturel de
l'histoire la vôtre celle de votre
famille celle de votre entreprise ça de
votre territoire voire même celle de
votre pays et c'est la question c'est
quand est ce qu'on arrive à extraire ses
racines parce que le l'enjeu là il est
d'arriver à sortir tranquillement des
racines ce qui s'y trouve pour le mettre
en débat pour conscientiser les choses
et sortir des non dits qui sont pourtant
si fréquent et c'est toute la difficulté
est ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
traduit la croix de confiance en un
outil d'extraction si je peux dire qu
est un outil qui permet de sortir des
racines ce qui s'y trouve ça se présente
sous forme d'une application web et
mobile d'un outil web et mobile qui est
basé sur une série de questions qui sont
posées et qui permettent de définir
individuellement ou collectivement la
couleur de votre art de confiance et les
résultats de ceux de ce2 ce2 ce2 cet
arbre il se retrouve dans un document du
tort de dire rapport très simple très
rapide à faire automatique
évidemment et qui peut servir de
discussion de des changes avec un
professionnel de l'accompagnement qui a
été formé pour cela
ça peut être un coach un consultant
informateur un enseignant un travailleur
social un médiateur et l'enjeu en fait
il est justement d'arriver ensemble à
prendre conscience de ses propres
croyances de ses propres son propre
héritage social de sa propre histoire
pour comprendre exactement de quelle
couleur on est et où est-ce qu'on est
plutôt d'être rouge et sur quoi on
aurait intérêt à travailler en priorité
pour faire revenir aux verts un arbre de
confiance qui serait peut-être d'une
autre couleur jusque là alors vous
pourriez me demander à juste titre
pierre
toi là ton art de confiance la sicile
étaient au rouge vif sur le droit et
cheikhou à l'erreur qu'est ce que tu
fait concrètement pour agir là dessus
alors je vais être honnête avec vous
j'ai pas de formule miracle
1 j'ai pas de recette miracle mais j'ai
quand même des petites choses que j'ai
essayé de mettre en oeuvre depuis un
certain temps et que je vais partager
que je vais juste vous de vous donner
comme ça rapidement
la première c'est d'oser dire les choses
d'oser dire nous et partager les erreurs
qu'on peut commettre les échecs qu'on
peut éventuellement avoir et demander de
l'aide
demander de l'aide oser demander de
l'aide et c'est pas facile aussi bien et
j'essaie de le faire vis-à-vis de moi
vis-à-vis de ma famille de mes enfants
de mes des gens avec qui je travaille et
c'est vrai que plus on est dans une
situation de pouvoir de responsabilité -
c'est naturel de faire cet exercice là
évidemment or c'est là que c'est le plus
important de le faire
la deuxième chose c'est peut-être
d'essayer de de réduire un peu ses
ambitions ses exigences vis-à-vis de
soi-même
voyez de faire un peu d'ouvrir le petit
moucheron delà de la cocotte-minute
et ça ça peut faire du bien de soulever
la pression de réduire la pression ça ça
peut être aussi vraiment très utile
et ça ça renvoie aux prunes de l'égout
ce qui est pas une mince affaire on soit
évidemment
alors tout ce que je vous dis là c'est
que ce qui me réjouit aujourd'hui c'est
que l'arbre de confiance eh bien ils
commencent à pousser et à grandir non
seulement dans des entreprises et des
institutions mais et mais aussi dans des
écoles et sage tous absolument
extraordinaire il y as a certes pourquoi
quoi mesurer la confiance et à agir sur
la confiance entre des enfants des
parents et des enseignants
il ya une chose qui m'a tout à fait
fasciné c'est ce que quand j'ai posé la
question à des ados 13 14 ans qui avait
fait leur arbre de confiance j'aurais
demandé avec qui est ce que vous auriez
envie de discuter des résultats de votre
arbre confiance est ce que vous savez ce
qui me répondu avec nos parents abbas
que vous le croyez ça moi je vous dois
vous dire que je me suis revu à cet
âge-là 13 14 ans et j'ai pas vous est-ce
que vous ciboure pu le placer à cet âge
là est ce que vous auriez facilement
discuter de votre art de confiance un
sujet aussi sensible que ça quand même
avec vos propres parents c'est pas
forcément si évident que ça eh ben je me
suis dit que si on avait la trouver
quelque chose qui permettait de
développer les relations de confiance
entre des jeunes et leurs parents et
aussi entre des parents et les
enseignants
je me disais que là on faisait vraiment
oeuvre utile alors mon autre source de
satisfaction c'est que cet arbre il est
né en france mais une grandit pas qu'en
france il grandit déjà dans des écoles
en ukraine dans des entreprises et des
institutions en europe et aux états unis
auprès de gouvernements de pays
d'afrique donc un peu partout dans le
monde parce qu'on s'est rendu compte que
la confiance et la défiance et ben c'est
un problème universel
alors si je suis là aujourd'hui devant
vous c'est parce que je souhaite
partager une conviction c'est que la
confiance ça se cultive et comme un
arbre eh bien il faut l'entretenir
sinon il perd ses feuilles et finit par
mourir alors ce que ce à quoi j'aimerais
vous inviter ses à avoir envie je
l'espère de peut-être chacun d'entre
vous vous dire que vous avez peut-être
envie de prendre de prendre un petit
arbre de confiance et de le faire
grandir
là où vous pouvez au niveau qui est le
vôtre chacun et je suis sûr que chacun
peut le faire que ce soit à la maison
dans votre entreprise dans l'école de
vos enfants et en fait l'idée c'est
l'enjeu c'est de que vous soyez chacun
des ambassadeurs de confiance quelque
part je suis convaincu d'une chose c'est
que si nous tous nous faisons cela est
bien de petits arbres de confiance un
petit peu partout on arrivera ensemble à
faire grandir une véritable forêt de
confiance et c'est ça l'enjeu est pour
passer de la parole aux actes
et bien ce que je vous inviterai à faire
c'est si vous en êtes d'accord ceux
d'entre vous qui ont envie de cultiver
cette confiance avec moi et là où vous
pouvez passer deux à l'issue de cette de
cette séance est avant la pause et ba2
lorsque vous vous levez devenir
symboliquement arrosé un petit arbre de
confiance avec l'arrosoir que vous
trouverez là là il ya des petits arbres
à côté
la merci de venir pour les arroser merci
beaucoup